uh thank you so much for having me um
yeah so thanks for bearing with me last
Talk of the day it's always hard I know
everyone is a little bit sleepy but you
know there's exciting stuff in here
um you know first question might be wait
what are we doing here you know like
this pycon Pi data you know like
shouldn't this be really Python and you
know like this is what I want to start
with like everybody knows spark but
spark is this weird Scala Beast you know
like jvms and stuff like wait what does
this have to do with python so my number
one question and I really take this from
a previous speaker because I like the
interactivity so how many people here
have used spark before
oh wow nice oh I'm you know I'm a
database person I come from C plus plus
background like all of this color stuff
is still new to me a little bit so many
people are using pi spark in kind of a
regular basis
oh man that's awesome so how many people
love debugging Pi spark stuff
I mean one person loves it well I mean
that's much more than anticipated you
know and you know the reason is the
evolution of spark you know spark you
know back in the days build
in a way that we typically today
associate with large data centers large
clusters so we've built all of these
applications and everybody that has ever
deployed like this ml app this kind of
iot app on spark essentially really
boils down to like deploying it together
with spark there's no concept really of
deploying an app next to spark it's like
always one thing and the reason is oops
are there's a slight missing the reason
is that everything in spark essentially
is really tied down into the the spark
driver this is like this whole jvm
interop between like Python and jvm like
this is really hard
but you know data applications as we've
seen like many different places they
don't live in data centers anymore just
in data centers anymore it's like
everybody wants to use like python for
development vs code jupyter notebooks we
want to write web applications not just
in Python because we love it but you
know there's like weirdly there's other
languages like go and JavaScript you
know that people want to use and then
the other hand like we have these Edge
devices like everybody has a phone like
with lots of computing power like we
have like all of this other stuff in the
questions like why can't I use spark
from these devices like why do I have to
always think and Spark in terms of like
I have to deploy this using kubernetes I
have to go to Amazon pay lots of money
or data breaks yay
um but you know at the end of the day
it's like why is it so complicated and
really if you zoom in you know as I said
before your application logic sits right
on top of the uh the whole spark stack
so it's like right next to the analyzer
or the optimizer before gets scheduled
and executed
but if I want to embed spark in my
application like I get to this kind of
big problem I have to use SQL I mean SQL
is awesome you know don't get me wrong
but everybody that has tried to build
like a dynamic app using SQL knows that
it ends up being like string
concatenation like everybody that ever
said like oh you know let's just add a
dynamic filter to my SQL string here
yeah right you built like a CTE and then
with statement and another one but wait
how do I debug this you know this and
then you know you talk to data Engineers
they said oh have you used data frames
and say yeah no because while data
frames not really work there so a
question is like SQL only but if I want
to use my IDE my notebook the things
that I'm used to I'm a software engineer
you know I don't like notebooks for
developing code you know notebooks are
awesome you know for interactive stuff
or like you know like doing stuff like
really ad hoc but if I run an if I want
to develop an ETL pipeline I don't use a
notebook I mean you know don't get me
wrong I mean if I say this out loud you
know half of my company is going to yell
at me because they believe notebooks are
awesome they are but for their own kind
of of purpose but if I want to use an
idea notebook I have to basically deploy
my code close to the rebel the wrapper
is basically enough we know it's in
Python this runs like right next to
spark which means I have to run spark
locally or I have to SSH to know the Run
spark and this is complicated if I want
to use a programming language that does
not have any kind of inter or with the
jvm I can't use spark at all if I want
to use go I'm kind of toast there is
spark R but everybody that has ever done
anything really with software
engineering and Spark are I mean it's
saying it works but
you know it's it's a whole different
piece
all right so this is the reason why over
the last year essentially we built spark
connect the whole goal of spark
connectors build this kind of Thin
Client API that allows you to use the
power of spark from anywhere like using
it from I'm so using it from your Ides
from your applications from all these
kind of different programming languages
so how do we achieve this when we looked
at the way how the spark API is
essentially built like the data frame
API the key apis that basically have
evolved over the last 10 years there's
really like we have this data frame API
that gives us a declarative perspective
of how to access the data if I'm saying
like spark read table then select and
write an insert into all of this is like
declaratively identifying like what kind
of operations I want to do on my
workloads we take this API we translate
it into logical path plan path plan why
Paris plan because on the client side we
don't really know like is this a table
is this a file is this parquet is this
CSV is this Json we want this
information is handled best at the spark
server so we want to push this there we
then take this unresolved logical plan
we send it off the wire using grpc and
then we process it on spark you can use
all the plugins that you're using in
spark you can use all the power of spark
the spark ecosystem that you have today
continue using it and use spark connect
and then the results are streamed back
using grpc and arrow data now to the
client
so
the we start the project with this spark
Improvement proposal roughly in May
2022 and now with spark 3.4 actually the
first version that spark 3.4 was
released last Friday is available as
open source and you can use it you can
directly get started so what is the
status of spark connect in spark 3.4
today
essentially if you're using python for
all of your data science and all your
data management or data engineering
processes like it just works out of the
box you can use data frame apis UDF
Dynamic conf all of this all of this is
there we even have like an experimental
scholar client that allows you to use
more or less the the untyped data set
apis from Scala and use it as well and
connect them remotely from IntelliJ for
example to your spark cluster without
like SSH into something however there's
a trade-off you know like this sounds
like oh man this is so awesome like why
haven't you done this like 15 years ago
and the answer is you know spark is 12
years old so there's a lot of evolution
that has happened in the different apis
of the system and you know there are
parts of spark that still exist as the
powerful but they're not really client
friendly so rdds for example you know
like I don't know if people remember
like the rdd paper from like 14 years
ago already I mean I'm way too old it
seems
um you know this was like the beginning
of like why spark is so successful and
rdd API is kind of like this powerful
improvement over mapreduce and really
show like what you can do with that new
kind of in-memory processing but the
downside is they're very low level the
data frame API is like high level
declarative implementation and rdds are
this kind of low level I really know
what I'm doing the assembly so to say of
like data processing but doing this on
the client side if you want to debug
from your python application this is
really not the way what you want to do
so here's really we're saying okay
please don't use rdds and we don't
support rdds in this API
and essentially we are giving a
simplification from this kind of three
different apis that you have today in
spark to only two focusing on the
declarative apis that can be optimized
using the built-in Optimizer Catalyst
and so on
um if you have your application and you
want to migrate to spark connect today
there's a couple of things to be aware
of you know number one that is you know
for some people a little bit surprising
is you don't have access to the driver
jvm anymore there are surprisingly many
like even python applications that
somehow use Java under the hood and you
know you might not even be aware of that
but this is something that because now
your client doesn't run anymore on the
spark cluster you don't have access to
the driver jvm anymore in addition the
spark context as this kind of like
application single and is not available
in the same way and we believe this is
doesn't fit really on the client because
it's a server side concept
so how like what's the ux then like what
does actually change so to basically
show you how to connect to spark a
remote spark class if we added this kind
of remote property to the spark session
Builder which identifies the spark
cluster given a connection string the
connection string of a spark connect is
very similar to any jdbc connection
string so basically saying like hey this
is my host name that I want to connect
to that support number and so on
spark connect as a protocol as I
mentioned is grpc based so it's standard
HTTP 2 so wherever you can deploy any
kind of HTTP 2 traffic today you can use
spark connect it works really easy in
databricks we run it behind an Envoy
proxy I talked to tense customers in the
last couple of weeks there's like NY
proxy we talked about integrating this
in QB and they're like many different
open source projects that give you this
kind of flexibility of deploying HTTP 2
proxies
so in spark 3.4 as I said sparkling is
available it's publicly documented it's
all in docs and you know what's even
better is in in spark essentially now
they have these kind of live notebooks
that are supported by mybinder so it's
basically running a Docker container
with spark inside where you then can run
interactively try this out in your
browser and run this quick start
notebook for spark connect to really get
like an idea of like how to how to use
the system
all right you know but the thing is all
of this is open source you know but I
get paid by a different company and so I
want to talk to you a little bit about
like where does spark connect come into
play for data breaks and like why do we
believe this is so important in such a
game Shader for us as well
so as I mentioned before you know spot
connect gives you the ability to connect
to your data lake house like from
anywhere and this is really what we care
about like databricks is the the number
one provider for data lake house
platforms for giving you the ability to
collect your data process your data do
machine learning on top of it integrate
this into your envelopes flows and
everything so wherever your data is
whatever your problem or whatever you're
trying to do with your data we basically
give you the opportunity to integrate
with us and then using databricks
connect which is built on top of spark
connect you can then integrate from all
different areas so this is not just IDs
and notebooks but this is as well data
applications so you've seen outside
there's a boost from broadly you know
like we've shown like how to integrate
with properly streamlined all of these
kind of like new kind of data
application tools that give you this
interactive experience and then of
course we have partner Integrations
using data IQ that are all using the
same API to build new kinds of
applications for the data Lake
so why do we care so much about IDE
based development because developers
like it you know like if you're using
database today you're thrown into web
interface and then you have a notebook
and this is you get started and you know
this is awesome you know like you built
your first pipeline you schedule this as
a job this is great but at some point
I'm asking is how do I write a unit test
how do I test this and then somebody
says oh I found a GitHub project that
allows you to run Pi test in a notebook
and say awesome that's really what I
always wanted like this is what I
dreamed of my whole life
um I don't you know I still believe that
unit tests are run locally
um but and the question is like how do
we basically give customers and users
the ability to use all the muscle memory
that they learned over time you know
they all went to like School University
like what kind of whatever wherever they
learn their best practices you want to
give them the ability to use this you
know so we want to say okay whatever you
learned and whatever fits your job the
way that you want to do your tasks the
best we want to give you the opportunity
to continue using this so This Is Why We
Believe like it's not just in the
notebook it's from everywhere yeah in
databricks we had something called
dbconnect V1 so to say this was our
first approach to this topic and it
works it's kind of clunky it does its
job but it's not really extensible it's
not really fast and you know like this
project has been a maintenance for a
couple of years and now basically with
databricks with spark connect
essentially we're pushing completely new
way forward in a much more lightweight
way
so what it allows you DB connectors like
whenever you have a databricks cluster
somewhere running a new infrastructure
you can connect from anywhere from the
IDE of your choice being at pycharm
being at vs code or whatsoever and you
get the benefits of not just having like
debugging but you know like the larger
your company gets the more you know
sophisticated your processes are around
data like data governance becomes
important for you as well so it's no
longer just oh can I write my unit test
but it's like can I write my unit test
in a way that still respects like you
know all of the data governance routes
that I have set up in my in my company
so and this is really what we want to do
and to get started it's very simple you
know like since today essentially we're
going uh public preview today pip
install database connect depending uh
version larger than 13 and now you can
connect to your database cluster from
anywhere directly from your laptop from
wherever you want and it's very simple
to get started all that you need as I
said you need the package you take your
workspace URL your cluster ID and off
you go I know this is kind of like hey
this is not a database show but you know
just to like if you look at the slides
later on it's very easy to get started
so again you know like our goal was like
how do we make this backwards compatible
like for us the really the most
important part is there's so much code
written today in pi spark you know that
you want to continue using we don't want
to push on you or we don't want to
prescribe you a particular way how you
have to continue
of writing your code from now on we want
to make sure that the same open source
way of using pi spot continues in the
same way and that you can simply use it
but you're using it now on databricks so
you know if you take this example you
can run this like on Legacy or Legacy
unlike plain vanilla Pi spark it works
you can run this on databricks it works
you can move this to DB connect and it
works you know this is what we wanted to
achieve we want to make sure that
whatever we're doing it's compatible to
the back to to the existing versions so
this is just like an animated gif that I
did some time ago you know like to show
you hey how easy it is now to basically
interact with remote cluster so in this
particular example I just wrote a simple
test where I'm like scanning a table on
my remote cluster and I set a breakpoint
because my test was failing and now I'm
basically you know everything that I'm
used to basically being able to debug my
code locally in Python I can still do so
I can get all the benefits that pycharm
offers me in this case to like inspect
all the values I can interact with the
system but my Pi spark is not running
locally I don't have have this pie charm
I don't use what's called IntelliJ Fleet
or something like this where you now
have like remote running instances of
your IDE no this is my patch I'm running
locally on my MacBook that connects
using spark connect to remote cluster
and this is can be whatever it can be
single cluster can be 100 node class I
can have a terabyte table can have a 20
megabyte table it doesn't matter like
all of the things that all of the data
that is available to me I can use and
this is really the power because imagine
you have your complex ETL pipelines and
you're trying to debug why for whatever
reason your ZIP code all of a sudden
contains a letter while you didn't
expect this because in Germany all the
zip codes are actually numbers Until you
realize in England it's not the case you
know and but you really like how do you
do this yes you can write a unit test
but sometimes you just want to look at
the data and this is really what you
know the difference again like it brings
back this combination of like the ad hoc
interactive analysis of the data
and combines it you know with the um you
know the standard software engineering
approaches
in addition to just local development
you know this enables a whole different
area of completely new use cases you
know it becomes very easy to write
completely new interactive data
applications with very little code that
you need so for example as I mentioned
like we have a public GitHub repository
that shows how to use a dash and plotly
with our sample data sets in I think
roughly I would say net lines of code is
probably 100 lines of code to give you
this kind of interactive map
visualization where every time you're
changing something it like actually goes
back to the server and runs a full query
you know yes of course you could do this
today already but just with SQL but
again now you have Pi spark available
you can really leverage all of the
benefits of that and then another one is
we have a
partnership with data IQ where data IQ
is a provider that builds local no code
ETL pipelines and they have a breakout
where you can write Pi spark code
essentially to integrate with databricks
and now they don't have to like run this
as a notebook or a job in database they
can interactively trigger this from
their pipeline making it very easy to
combine SQL push down with a pi Spike
push down and all of the other
operations that they have in their
systems
and you know as I said you integrate
from any application like you can take
this example you know this is the most
minimal it doesn't produce this awesome
map there but the most minimal example
to run a Dash app is exactly these kind
of like 10 lines of code that you can
deploy in a Docker container run it
anywhere and just use it and then you
have basically a new application
deployed using spark you don't need to
explain why a new kind of like data
management system you can continue using
all of your existing data science tools
that you have
you know partner integration as
mentioned
um data IQ really the ability of pushing
down additional Pi spark code directly
to the spark cluster and making it
available so that because again the
interesting part is coming back to the
previous talk
um it's you're not the only Persona in
the company well like the data
scientists basically writing code like
they of course they know what they're
doing but there are many users out there
that really look at this and say like I
understand half of it if I'm lucky but
most of the time I can like roughly
point and click you know and that's why
there's so much success in this kind of
local no code tools because they give
you the ability of like onboarding users
and onboarding like knowledge that you
couldn't access before however most of
the time these kind of tools had a
limitation that there's a limit to the
complexity that you can express with the
integration that we're doing here with
data IQ you really get the ability of
saying like I can onboard the users that
have a good understanding of the
business case and they can express it
but in addition I can offer them the
ability to push down even more complex
logic if they need to
um again like this is my job as database
personality I have to basically give you
an idea of a roadmap so we got went to
the public preview today like you know
the US is waking up so I'm expecting the
blog post to be published in the next
hour or so
um so today we have support for Python
and Pi spark ml flow support is there
for single node ml
um authentication and standard token
based authentication 80 percent Azure
gcp is coming the next couple of weeks
and you know as we are Marching towards
GA of the product like our our goal is
to have full support of the panels on
spark API as well
um the ability we will run Scala support
in a private preview and as well full
depth of support you know like for us
it's not just the on the client side the
just reading the data but as well
writing the data using the power of the
open Delta Lake to be able to integrate
and as part of that comes as well like
making sure that we have the full
Enterprise Integration oauth and Azure
ID and so on and then in the longer term
roadmap you know R again comes up
because there are customers especially
in financial sector that are using R and
it will it will not go away I mean we
had the discussion earlier about like uh
Kobo you know like it's been dying to
it's been trying to die for a long time
it's not happening I mean I think you
know like R will have the sign of came
the the kind of same Faith you know like
it will remain there and we have to make
sure that we pick up the users from
where they are
and with that I conclude my presentation
and I'm happy to answer any kind of
questions that you might have on this
topic thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you so much Martin uh we have a
bunch of questions on slido so I'm just
gonna jump into the first one does spark
connect provide a mechanism to
instantiate a remote spark cluster uh no
so spark connect is really more the
connection protocol
um in spark so there are two open source
projects that give you the ability to
create the spark classes like one would
be QB which is a relatively new one that
is more like a SQL Gateway on top of
spark and then there is another one that
I forgot which name it is was kind of
dead but was just recently reanimated so
it's it's not so spark connects job is
not like instantiating the spark cluster
there are other open source projects
doing that sparkling is remodel protocol
great how does UDF X how does UDF
execute it now
um so the udfs the python udfs are
executed in the same way and so
basically we and this is I don't even
dare to say this like we Cloud pickle uh
the UDF closure and we send it over the
wire and this comes with all of the
downsides that you've heard before
um that's unfortunately the way that in
pi spark the UDF execution works we
don't try to change this if anybody here
is interested in like doing something
that is better than Cloud picker and
more portable like please let me know
like I'm totally happy to figure out a
way how we get this in in pi spark but I
think like Cloud pick unfortunately is
the two-day solution okay
is the same databricks connect code I
wrote locally be prod compatible if I
would if I were to deploy it in deploy
it to databricks Via CI CD or terraform
or do I need to adjust it no essentially
the goal is that the code that you're
writing locally even if you're using pi
spark open source locally that this code
is prod compatible like we want to
improve the Fidelity of the inner def
Loop of the engineers
very cool
is it possible to see afterwards from
which source the code ran for example
for cost analysis to check whether unit
tests that need clusters are increasing
costs
um so you have the visibility into from
where the the chords came mostly by the
users that ran on your clusters so the
same cost attribution that you're having
on your existing database classes all of
this works in the same way so there's no
specific check for like blogging for
dbconnect access
okay
for unit testing spark apps in cicd cicd
is it possible to have a local spark
version or environment in Standalone
mode that is identical to the databricks
runtime
um completely identical to the data
breaks runtime is a little bit hard
because you know as data breaks you know
we have our own belts and whistles that
we have like a roundhouse Park runtime
um however like from a core
functionality perspective like a local
Pi spark gives you roughly the
capabilities of the respective database
version of course you know if you're
installing your local libraries you have
to make sure that they're installed as
well on the device cluster
okay so far so far in my experience uh
Pi spark is much lower than native SQL
in data bricks is it the nature we only
use is it the nature we only use Pi
spark when SQL couldn't do more advanced
analytics
um so in theory that shouldn't be the
case because Pi spark and SQL boil down
to the same execution engine they they
boil down to the same execution plans
and they run through the same analyze
and Optimizer I mean this like a good
example to see this is if you're
searching for spark SQL you're actually
not finding SQL text but you're finding
like all the like SQL spark SQL means
data frames essentially so that's why
it's very unlikely that SQL code like
string SQL is can be much faster than Pi
spark because it's the same if you're
using if you're like injecting rdd
somewhere in the middle like it becomes
a opaque optimization blocker if you're
using udfs obviously they become slower
so sometimes you know people I've seen
customers and users basically instead of
calling you know this the the pi spark
uh the pi spark SQL function like upper
basically creating a UDF that does
string upper you know because it's
convenient like they didn't remember
then the function name in SQL so they
just wrote a small UDF that does this I
mean obviously this is like tons slower
than uh just using the native SQL
functionality but otherwise it should be
the same performance
okay when would you recommend using one
of the other methods to run spark in ide
namely vs code Plugin or databricks
extension dbx
um so the vs code extension like we're
integrating right now with the vs code
extension this will the views code
extension will be updated as well to
support the native debugging
capabilities
um the the reason for using the existing
let's say dbx way of synchronizing the
code to notebook and databricks is
mostly if you're using not the most
recent release of the database runtime
so if you are for unfortunate reasons
stuck on an old release then you have to
use the old ways if you can migrate to
the database 13 release which was
released last Friday then you can use
the new way of connecting to databricks
okay
are there plans to integrate Kerberos
off
um no and the reason is
in spark generally we try not to be
prescriptive of the way that you deploy
your cluster I mean if you look at spark
you can deploy like using kubernetes
using yarn using whatever you want like
local cluster mode and like Kerberos
essentially is one way of doing
authentication but like this is
something that we believe should be
handled outside of spark connect and
outside of of this particular
implementation this is something where
like a proxy in front of spark connect
is a much better place to do this kind
of authentication than trying to hook
this into the spark connect protocol
itself
okay
how can the cluster dynamically check if
it is if it if it is started locally or
from databricks UI because depending on
this on that session construction
differs doesn't it
I'm trying to unpack this
um so the easiest way to check how the
cluster was started I think is checking
the master property in spark in the
spark fund which should tell you if
you're running in local mode or if you
have a master URL set but I think I'm
not 100 sure what the question tries to
get it so it would be great to rephrase
it and like give me a little bit more
hints on like where this goes to we
still have time for questions so whoever
has that question can we ask it again or
maybe we have another question from the
audience
or we can go to coffee break five
minutes early what would you prefer
okay uh thank you so much Martin that
was a great talk
[Applause]